it's that time of year when your
favorite series are back like this is us
the good place the better things and
even willing grace but there are also in
them or a brand new network and
on-demand shows that are sure to blow
you away here's a rundown of the shows
are premiered in fall of 2017 that you
should definitely make some time for the
mayor the time is right for a new
political comedy to step up and help us
temporarily escape from real-life drama
and ABC's the mayor is here to help
centering around the charismatic Brandon
Michael halls character Courtney Rose an
aspiring rapper who gets elected mayor
after running for office as a publicity
stunt the mayor could potentially be
crowned the season's best new comedy
it's funny refreshingly light-hearted
and optimistic and it certainly has our
vote of confidence future man if Seth
Rogen is releasing a project it should
probably be on your radar the
well-established funny man is once again
teaming up with Evan Goldberg to take on
the end of the world a favorite topic of
the two decision creators with their
show future man Rogen and Goldberg are
looking to stand out from the comedy
crowd with their own patented brand of
humor in an interview of sci-fi wire
Rogen and Goldberg said that they prefer
very high stakes comedy and a future man
is exactly that people could die he's
second to us that's that's the funniest
I don't know why it's probably cuz we're
sick
Star Trek discovery as the first new
Star Trek show in more than a decade
Star Trek Discovery is under some
serious pressure to perform setting the
expectations even higher is the fact
that it takes place after Star Trek
Enterprise and before the original
series of the 1960s meaning discovery
needs to successfully maintain
continuity if it wants to please a
franchise's hard core fan base luckily
fans have tweeted out their positive
reactions so perhaps all systems are
indeed ago with the Karris Mattox and
equal martin green headlining a cast of
almost all new characters discovery
should please longtime Trekkies and the
newcomers alike smith show times hottest
new series this fall is undoubtedly
smith about a basketball-playing man
chasing south boston woman who also
happens to be a single mother raising a
toddler Smith rise in his authentic feel
thanks to writer producer director and
star Frankie Shah who claims a show a
semi-autobiographical
with Rosie O'Donnell the shores mother
and the Nashville's Connie Britton on
board
it looks like Showtime is set to score a
big win with smilk big mouth if adult
themed animated comedies are your thing
look no further than Netflix it's
definitely not family-friendly series a
big mouth which follows two teenagers
and the throes of puberty as they battle
hormone monsters and a newfound
adolescent interests throw in a
star-studded cast featuring comedy
favorites like Nick Kroll Maya Rudolph
John Mulaney and Jordan Peele to name a
few and the fact that Netflix has
already proven itself with adult
animated shows and the big mouth is sure
to be a home run you have a really big
mouth thank you I think the Duce can't
get enough of James Franco and HBO's new
series seduced is for you featuring the
actor and not one but two leading roles
while also working behind the scenes as
an executive producer and director the
drama follows 20 brothers Vincent and
Frankie Martino both played by Franco
during the early days of New York City's
adult movie industry the creators of the
series have boy laid out their plan of
exactly how they wanted to go with eight
episodes per season for three seasons in
an interview with Collider Franco said I
think if we pull it off it will be a
really nice encapsulation of a time and
a place
young Sheldon CBS's ultra popular sitcom
The Big Bang Theory was destined to get
a spinoff and here it is
young Sheldon sent us around child
genius Sheldon Cooper but the
similarities stop there and like its
parent sitcom young Sheldon has no
studio audience and it has a more
sentimental family-oriented tone well
not be excited when he's gonna be in the
same grade as me don't worry Georgie I'm
not planning on being in the ninth grade
for very long this stylistic change in
format works in a spin-off favor
as does the standout work of Ian
Armitage as the title character whether
you're a fan of the Big Bang Theory or
not you'll definitely want to give them
more mature young Sheldon a chance law
based on errand monkeys popular podcast
of the same name Amazon's lore is set to
dominate the horror genre the Seas
the series first season will run for six
episodes with each episode acting as a
standalone horror story running the
gamut from demons to medical experiments
gone wrong if rites are your thing be
sure to check out law American vandal
whether you love or hate true crime
documentaries you'll certainly get a
kick out of Netflix's self satirizing
spoof American vandal the series
Lampoon's you're too familiar genre by
focusing on the crime and punishment of
dillon maxwell a high schooler expelled
for drawing male genitalia across 27
automobiles because everyone heard it in
what in what ensues is an utterly
brilliant deconstruction of everyone's
favorite to binge worthy guilty pleasure
and it's one you definitely don't want
to miss the gifted Marvel series are
always met with anticipation and the
gifted is no different so far fans and
critics agree it's delivering in a big
way the gift it excels in both its
premise a mutant family on the run from
The Sentinel services and the special
effects it uses for its mutant powers
whether you're an x-men fan or nuts
the gifted Zim pressive casts will quite
literally blow you away thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]